wir üben täglich für den ernstfall und
sind bereit
es ist einmal grundsätzlich fliegen
fliegen ist einfach so unvorstellbar das
ist beruf über einstellungen die man für
österreich macht und aus einer
persönlichen überzeugung aus
die ausbildung beim bundesheer ist
ausgezeichnet zum einen weil dieses
aufgabenspektrum relativ groß ist das
wird auch im einsatz abdecken müssen das
heißt wir müssen aber unsere jungen
piloten dementsprechend in dem gesamten
einsatzspektrum dann ausbilden und da
sah man vor sehr breit gefächert und das
macht das ganze ja viel viel
interessanter
egal ob lawinen waldbrände
hochwasserkatastrophen ist es natürlich
mit dem hubschrauber sehr nützlich wenn
die hilfe direkt aus der luft kommt die
beweglichkeit der hubschrauber bietet
und die einsatzmöglichkeiten sind dafür
ideal
neben der vorbereitung auf unsere
militärische aufgabe sind natürlich
jederzeit für die katastropheneinsätze
verfügbar und jederzeit bereit auch dort
in seinen einsatz zu zeigen
positiv abgeschlossen einsatz es gibt
einfach selber persönlich gutes gefühl
landesverteidigung ist chemie einfach
ein gutes gefühl für österreich muss tun
zu können
[Musik]